from Jets to electric vehicles and
supercomputers the US is fighting to
lead the world in a variety of
Industries especially against China we
break down how American technology
engineering and science stack up against
its Chinese competitors our first story
is about China's first homegrown narrow
body Jet and how it compares to Western
standards like the Boeing 737
this is comac c919 China's first
homegrown narrow body jet that's been in
the works for more than a decade this is
a 737 Max 8 Boeing's popular narrow body
plane among Airlines worldwide
this type of plane can cover lots of
domestic and InterContinental routes
accounting for more than half of the
global passenger aircraft Fleet
and that's a big reason why Beijing
hopes its own model can compete with
Western giants like Boeing and become
the main carrier at home eventually one
day taking on the global airspace
so we compare the design and Technology
of both planes to see how China's deep
Reliance on Western Parts could sign the
beijing's ambition to challenge its U.S
rival
Boeing has more than 100 years of
experience with commercial Aviation
China in comparison started exploring
the industry in the 1970s but for
several decades wasn't able to develop
its own airliner so Boeing became one of
China's go-to companies in China Boeing
has had a great couple decades Richard
abulafia is managing director with
aerodynamic advisory and Aerospace and
defense consultancy based in Michigan
for more than 30 years he's been
tracking Global Aviation markets with
Boeing as one of his main focuses if you
look back at China economic growth and
air travel demand growth it really took
off in the 90s and sometime in the 2000s
that began to translate into very large
jetliner sales numbers Boeing strutliner
sales hit a record high in 2017. the
American Giants sent more than 200
planes to China that's about a quarter
of all its deliveries that year it also
has a 737 completion and delivery plan
there today about 40 percent of China's
passenger Fleet comes from with more
than half of the planes held by the
European giant Airbus which also has an
assembly plant in China so in order to
reduce its Reliance on the two Western
jetliners the Chinese government has
been focused on comac which was
established in 2008 and Chinese
president Xi Jinping has especially been
keen on creating a domestic airliner
yeah
University
China hasn't revealed how much it's
invested in comac but some Aerospace
analysts estimate that the state-owned
company has received somewhere between
49 and 72 billion dollars in government
Aid that was and is a national goal for
uh for China to be able to compete
against the U.S and Boeing Alex krutz is
managing director with U.S based
Aerospace consulting firm Patriot
industrial partners and he's been
following comex programs for about seven
years
ultimately designing and building a
successful commercial our aligner is is
very technologically advanced for
countries to be able to do so to develop
a successful commercial airliner China
has been eyeing Western designs like
Boeing the two jets are both narrow
bodies with a single aisle they're also
about the same size and carry a similar
number of passengers
even the engines aren't too different
they're from CFM which is a joint
venture between General Electric and
Safran of France and they're very
similar engines with roughly similar
levels of Technology
both engines are models from the leap 1
series from CFM leap 1B is for Boeing
leap 1C is for comac but the max 8 and
the c919 need more than just the engines
to take off they need other systems like
the mechanical mechanical systems
landing gears or Management Systems
avionics for the cockpits these
components and their supply chains have
played a big role in establishing Boeing
as an industry leader over the years
with Decades of experience the American
company has developed steady
relationships with its partners and
suppliers at home and abroad and most of
them are close allies of the US it's
very much an international creation
Boeing's major International Partners
Japan Britain France Canada Italy
Germany and many others those
Partnerships have helped Boeing secure
some of the most Advanced Technologies
for its aircraft like the cockpit which
is the brain of the plane Commack also
needs a global supply chain to put the
c919 together especially from American
and European companies but Aerospace
analyst say some foreign suppliers have
been reluctant to provide
state-of-the-art components over
concerns about their intellectual
property
this is saddled the c919 with older
technology than the 737 Max 8 and even
the Airbus 320 Neo but this may not be
the biggest risk to the comac project
there's this I guess sword hanging over
the 919 and a lot of it does come down
to geopolitics the U.S has long accused
China as seeking to steal Advanced
Technologies for use in its military
which Beijing repeatedly denied in
January last year the Trump
Administration added comac to a list of
companies that it said supported China's
military curbing the plane
manufacturer's access to American
Technology and funding comac was later
removed from President Biden issued a
new list
the Chinese company didn't respond to a
request for comment about The Blacklist
and concerns over IP infringement as
well as whether geopolitical tensions
could pose a risk to its c919 program
even if these vulnerabilities was
sourcing critical western parts
disappeared Aviation experts say Comax
still has other challenges learning how
to build it conforming that is to say
each article is exactly the same as the
previous one that's a major challenge
that's one of the easiest places to
stumble and another stumbling block if
and when China goes Global the lack of a
worldwide support system for operators
to obtain c919 spare parts or receive
maintenance and repairs at the service
it aftermarket support for the airplanes
so there's vast networks that Boeing has
that comac has to develop
for Boeing the U.S giant also has its
own problems especially in the Chinese
market as trade tensions broke out
between the U.S and China in 2017
Beijing froze nearly all orders and
deliveries of Boeing's Plains since
early 2019 the country has also kept the
737 Max grounded after two fatal crashes
in Indonesia and Ethiopia
Boeing says it continues to work with
global regulators and customers to
safely return the 737 Max and seize
China as an important market for the
company's commercial planes urging
dialogue between Beijing and Washington
despite the challenges comac is moving
forward the c919 marked a major
milestone in September towards carrying
passengers and the company has plans to
develop a wide body plane as well but
for comeek to rival Boeing it'll be a
long and perhaps bumpy flight ahead
[Music]
this is Tesla's model 3 sedan and it's
the cheapest Tesla Model in China and
this is byd Seal sedan it looks very
similar and it's one of the company's
most expensive models but with this
range china-based byd has closed in on
Tesla's share of the EV Market in China
China accounts for more than half of all
EVS sold globally in 2022 and any
company that can own this Market will
have an advantage on dominating the
growing industry there's a potential
here for new General Motors for new
Fords to emerge and for China to be a
dominant player we compared byd and
Tesla's business strategy Technology and
Manufacturing to understand whose
position to win
to see byd's rapid growth in China just
look at retail sales charts byd which is
backed by Warren Buffett jumped from
13th Place in 2021 to the top spot in
2022 in that time its overall sales more
than tripled hitting 1.86 million cars
that's some half a million more cars
than Tesla we have a lot of respect for
the car companies in China they are the
most competitive in the world in terms
of volume the top car company producing
EVS in China is definitely byd the
caveat is that it's not a cool EV brand
yet and that's why they introduce a new
series of cars with specs that car
commentators would say matching Tesla's
model 3. so while this seal sedan sells
for roughly thirty thousand dollars some
byd models sell for half that with most
models having an all-electric or plug-in
hybrid option their strategy is really
to ensure that consumers have options
Tesla's Fleet on the other hand is all
electric unlike byd it's mainly
positioned as a premium vehicle a
revolutionary bet from the beginning
there was a kind of a belief among
traditional car companies that somebody
who would want an electric car was going
to be motivated by economic concerns the
cost of gasoline their thesis was let's
start at the top let's make a cool a
sexy car that appeals to luxury buyers
for the most part that bet has paid off
if you look at each company's profit
margins you can see Tesla exceeds byd
the company sells less vehicles with a
higher profit margin but in early 2023
Tesla slashed prices for its two most
popular electric car models reducing
prices in China by as much as 13 the
company said the cuts were possible
through engineering Innovations and cost
controls but these Cuts also came just
before China began withdrawing
decades-long subsidies for Ev buyers
it's time now for the market to become
more mature smaller companies that were
not profitable but who depended on these
subsidies and need to be able to do more
to stand on their own Tesla might have
the marketing power to whether the
subsidy crash but byd has its own
strength production specifically battery
production this is just a sample of some
businesses that byd operates as you can
see it's far more vertically integrated
byd has three main areas of business it
produces cars it produces batteries for
its car and it also produces chips
before byd was an electric vehicle
company its main focus was batteries and
this battery branch of its business
ensures stability along the supply chain
even while disruptions plagued its
competitors compare that to Tesla which
continues to Source the majority of its
batteries from outside suppliers there's
been this tension around Tesla from the
get-go over its ability to get cells the
idea was to be buying so many of them
from suppliers that they would have
pricing advantage and they could get the
cost down it hasn't come down as much as
they wanted or much as they thought but
it has come down dramatically although
the US government is investing in this
area of business even producing the raw
and intermediate ingredients that
compose battery cells requires
Outsourcing when you think about where
the ingredients for these cells come
from it's largely a China game at this
point I think about lithium something
like 70 percent of it is refined in
China it's kind of worrisome to people
here in the U.S byd uses its own blade
battery which is a lithium iron
phosphate battery known as lfp the lfp
battery is the primary EV battery in
China and is generally viewed as a
cheaper option since it doesn't use the
costly elements nickel and Cobalt but it
comes with a trade-off the batteries
range range is a real issue for U.S
consumers there is this mindset that
there just might be a reason why you
need to go 300 miles or more in a trip
and so that's one of the the big kind of
differences between the China and the US
market in line with Market preference
Tesla's standard range models in China
also use an lfp battery its version is
made by Chinese maker catl but its long
range models still use an NCM based
battery that's nickel Cobalt manganese
some even include aluminum it's more
expensive but can charge a car for
longer distances and in the US Tesla
primarily uses this type of battery but
this may be changing Tesla is taking a
page out of the Chinese Market's
Playbook using lfp batteries in lower
cost models so even as Tesla invests in
its own battery production in the US
it'll still depend on Chinese resources
for some time
the final challenge for Evie makers is
getting their cars where their consumers
are eyd has a home-based advantage in
the China Market the Tesla has gained
some with this Factory in Shanghai built
in 2019 this was the first of its kind
for Tesla and frankly for any foreign
automaker it got off the ground rather
quickly in large part because of the
support from the the local Chinese
government they wanted to help Tesla get
going the local government in Shanghai
granted Tesla a corporate income tax
rate of 15 percent through 2023 a
significantly lower rate than the
standard 25 percent the factory deal
helps slash production costs for cars
sold in the country and Tesla was also
able to get out of a joint venture
agreement for years if you were General
Motors or you were a Volkswagen and you
wanted to build cars in China you had to
share the profit you had to share the
running of that joint venture and Tesla
didn't want to give up that kind of
control today Tesla sells in over 30
countries with manufacturing plants in
the U.S China and Germany byd D having
taken over China is just beginning its
Global push its passenger EVS are
currently for sale in China and a
handful of other countries the US is not
yet one of those in part because of the
U.S China tensions right now it's hard
for any Chinese car company to say
they're making a foray into the U.S
market right now it's also hard for car
companies to just think about expanding
into Market by exporting their purely
without manufacturing locally the fight
for the global EV Market has a ways to
go in China the market needs to mature
on its own without government subsidies
while the U.S needs to dramatically
improve its supply chain in the country
and up its EB adoption rate as for the
companies themselves byd has yet to
fully articulate its plans to enter the
U.S passenger EV Market while China's
biggest EV maker faces pressure to
expand uid said customer satisfaction is
its main goal and top priority I've been
writing about the automotive industry
for almost 20 years and there's always
been this kind of belief that the
Chinese car companies were on the verge
of coming to the states we haven't
really seen that yet creating the
infrastructure to sell the vehicles is a
challenge Tesla did not respond to a
request for comment but the company also
faces its own obstacles ahead they need
to show growth to the investment
community and we have seen investors
really be forgiving at the idea of
chasing sales volume at the potential
cost of profitability if electric
vehicles are truly the future of the car
owning this Market could be Paramount to
a country's economy in order for that to
be a reality for Tesla EV batteries will
need to be made in America
this is the a100 chip from the U.S giant
Nvidia it's one of the world's most
advanced Computing processors which
helps develop artificial intelligence
that's used in everything from
self-driving cars to making drugs and
even building weapons
and this is one of its newest
competitors made by a Chinese startup
industry analysts who track the speed of
Chip say this model is even faster than
the a100 based on initial tests It
produced performances that were
significantly more competitive than
previous AI chips coming from China
here's how the design and capabilities
of these two chips compare as the race
for dominance in Tech is ramping up
the U.S has been a Pioneer in the
semiconductor industry for over 70 years
the U.S essentially gave birth to the
semiconductor industry and the
semiconductory economy Wayne lamb is the
director of research with tech
consulting firm CCS insight for over a
decade he has been researching American
chip technology the U.S was an ideal
place because it started much of the
research and core Sciences in the late
1940s American scientists invented the
first transistor the fundamental
technology behind all chips early
versions of chips fit inside computers
that helped calculate projectiles and
get NASA space programs off the ground
but the industry really took off in the
1960s with the rising demand for
consumer goods like televisions and
corporate computers
that boom also drove chip companies to
spring up across Asia with Taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company now
leading the industry making more than 90
percent of the world's most advanced
chips
still today the U.S is home to some of
the world's leading chip designers and
they help power everything from our
smartphones to laptops and data centers
China on the other hand has long been
trailing the U.S and for several decades
it is actually relied on American
companies as well as chip makers in
Taiwan and Japan
in 2021 China imported more than 430
billion dollars worth of chips exceeding
that of oil so Chinese president Xi
Jinping has made it a top priority to
change that it's absolutely important on
a strategic basis Gregory Allen is a
senior fellow at the center for
strategic and International Studies a
think tank based in Washington DC he's
been following beijing's Ai and
semiconductor policies for about seven
years
what they essentially wanted in the
semiconductor industry was for more of
the chips that were used in China to be
made in China so to become more
self-reliant Beijing promised to provide
about 180 billion dollars in state
funding to support its domestic chip
industry
the goal is to design chips that can be
as fast as the American ones like this
AI chip from Nvidia and this model
released in August by b-ren is the
latest demonstration of China's progress
like its American rival the b-ren chip
is also a graphics Processing Unit or
GPU and both are designed to help
computers perform complex tasks faster
so what makes a chip powerful to improve
their performance both companies are
using the same type of transistor
it's the fundamental unit that basically
controls the flow of electronic signals
and that allows the chips to store data
or run calculations
but unlike the first transistor invented
in the 1940s the ones today are so small
that they are measured in nanometers
which is a fraction of the width of a
human hair seven nanometer transistors
are now the base for both Nvidia and
b-ren's high-end chips so smaller to the
transistor the more transistors you can
pack into the same surface area of a
silicon the American ship is designed
with more than 54 billion transistors
over a plate of about 800 millimeter
square whereas the br100 is slightly
bigger with about 77 billion transistors
packed into about 1 000 Square
millimeters
while there are many factors that
determine a Chip's performance industry
experts say having a higher number of
transistors can help increase the
Chinese processor's speed brn says its
chip can perform more than one thousand
trillion operations per second at its
peak write it out that's 15 zeros that's
about three times the stated speed of
nvidia's a100
but whether biren will be able to
dominate the market will require more
than designing chips producing them is
also a huge challenge because it
requires precise manufacturing to
squeeze these billions of transistors
onto a tiny surface semiconductor
manufacturing is perhaps the most
technologically complicated thing that
the human species does one of the most
complex processes is called lithography
which blasts UV light through photo
masks and prints patterns on Silicon
Wafers adding layers to form the
transistors you need to be precise some
of the layers in the semiconductor
transistors are only one atom thick so
Nvidia and biren both look to another
company for manufacturing you may have
guessed that's the Taiwan semiconductor
Manufacturing Company the world's
largest contract chip producer
but Buren's Reliance on tsmc is becoming
a hurdle on its way to rivaling Nvidia
it has been sort of a cautionary tale
for the Chinese Semiconductor in history
a couple of months after the Chinese
startup releases chip the Biden
Administration imposed new export
restrictions the rules barred Cutting
Edge semiconductors made with American
Technologies from being sold to China
and because tsmc uses equipment from U.S
companies Buren is at risk of losing the
Taiwanese chip maker as a supplier this
dramatically reduces b-ren's prospects
for its future as a leading chip
designer Byron didn't respond to a
request for comment
tsmc says it complies with all laws and
regulations but declined to comment on
specific customers
China also depends on a handful of
American companies that dominate the
industry for advanced manufacturing
equipment with the American government
blocking China from buying these
machines it becomes even harder for
Beijing to build its own high-end chip
making factories
that development is perfectly an effort
to say the least so it would require
considerable investment in capital and
time to make that happen China isn't
alone in facing challenges and trying to
become more self-sufficient while the
U.S leads in design and research it is
also long relied on outside
manufacturers like tsmc and Samsung in
South Korea
and the vulnerability of that dependence
became an issue during the pandemic when
a chip shortage hit companies large and
small prompting President Biden to
promise that more semiconductors would
be produced in the U.S this is
infrastructure
so look we need to build infrastructure
of today not repair the one of yesterday
so in August he signed the chips act
allocating more than 52 billion dollars
in federal aid for Semiconductor
research and Manufacturing tsmc later
announced that it would invest 40
billion dollars to build two factories
in Arizona these Investments are helping
us build and strengthen the supply chain
here in America
and only months after the release of
China's br100 Nvidia announced that it
will release a super fast new chip which
would in turn beat b-runs the long and
expensive race to develop chips that'll
drive the future of AI is entering a new
phase
over the years Nike and China's
homegrown sportswear brand Anta have
rolled out a lot of sneakers and the
shoes from the Chinese company have made
appearances alongside Nike not only at
the Olympics but also on NBA courts in
2021 the companies released their latest
signature basketball shoes which
showcased the two Brands Flagship
midsoles that are designed for pro
athletes so we compare the high
performance technology from both
companies to see how ant is design is
one part of its plan to go Global and
gain ground on the world's biggest
sports brand
Nike has nearly 30 years on Anta and was
founded by people who love to run a
track and field coach and a middle
distance Runner the company from its
early days focused on designing shoes
for professional athletes and on the
other hand was set up in 1991 by a
father and his two sons to manufacture
shoes for other brands but after a few
years of that the company decided to
focus on creating its own shoes
runs a video Channel about basketball
shoes on the Chinese equivalent of
YouTube and he spoke to us about Anta
sneakers which are among the more than
500 pairs he's purchased over the past
five years
today Anta is China's top domestic
sportswear brand selling not just
Sneakers but also clothes and as part of
its ambition to go Global the company
has acquired a slew of international
Brands all this has helped make Anta the
world's fourth largest Athletic Apparel
company by market value
so to take on more established Brands
and has been rolling out signature
basketball shoes like Nike every year
each sneaker is named after an NBA
player LeBron is for LeBron James who's
considered one of the best players in
NBA history winning four championships
and this is his 19th pair of shoes with
Nike KT stands for Clay Thompson a
three-time NBA champion with the Golden
State Warriors who's famous for his
three-point shooting and this is his
seventh edition from his partnership
with Anta because the sneakers are
designed for individual players the
technology inside is different too there
are three main parts to the shoe and
this is where one of the most important
feature sits most of all what the
midsole will do is prevent injuries Zach
Thomas is a podiatrist based in
Pennsylvania
and he told us about the sneakers that
he's bought and sliced in half for his
YouTube channel so a good midsole phone
has a combination of spring back
forgiveness and a little bit of support
and stiffness will just make your foot
more efficient or make your foot work as
more of one unit instead of a bunch of
bag of bones
and that's especially important when
playing basketball because sudden stops
can shock the joints the midsole also
gives rebound which allows players to
jump higher so to make a strong midsole
both Anta and Nike have chosen the same
ingredient nitrogen but the two
companies are using the element
differently Nike is focusing on the
inert gas itself it's pumped into the
midsole of the LeBron 19 sneaker which
is made up of two air units in the
forefoot and rear foot the Air Max is
made from polyurethane and filled with
highly pressurized nitrogen that the
company says can absorb shocks the Zoom
Air is also a pressurized unit and
packed with tensile fibers Nike says
this helps the wearer spring upwards
after pushing down on it and in between
these two units is a chamber that
connects both so the air flows back and
forth so when you compress the forefoot
down here that air will shoot back into
the heel and vice versa and what that
does is it evens out the shoe it's
almost like ballast on a ship and so
it's going to keep you a little more
even but also it's going to produce a
little more Rebound in the areas of the
shoe where you would need it
is also looking to create better rebound
but it's using nitrogen to build a
different kind of structure the company
calls it nitrogen technology and first
introduced it with the seventh edition
of the Klay Thompson shoes
so the midsole is made up of a lot of
miniature bubbles of nitrogen that are
glued together the company says when
pressure is applied the bubbles compress
then expand giving the wearer both
cushioning and rebound this makes anta's
midsole very elastic but because it's
not contained in a pod like Nike's air
units Jong says the phone can easily
lose shape
[Music]
John and Thomas both agree that the two
midsoles perform well on courts and
that's because the shoes were
specifically designed for professional
athletes but that also means these shoes
aren't meant for everyone and ultimately
it's about making the technology go
mainstream and having ordinary people
buy and wear them once you develop it
for one thing it's pretty easy to to
reverse engineer for another sport
you just have to then figure out where
to put it in the shoe and doing this
well has helped Nike maintain a large
slice of the sportswear Market since the
invention of the Air Max in the late
1980s Nike has plugged it into a wide
range of sneakers from training shoes
that cost around eighty dollars to
basketball shoes that go for two hundred
dollars and Nike has developed a fleet
of other Technologies for example a
really thick midsole with a carbon fiber
plate inside that has helped Runners
break records but it's also sparked
controversies about whether the
technology provides athletes with an
unfair advantage and Nike also has a
lightweight thread material that the
company says gives wearers a secure fit
Nike doesn't disclose its r d budget but
investments in these technologies have
helped the company's Revenue more than
double in the past decade and Anta is
taking a similar path starting with the
kt7 which sells for about 150 dollars
the company says it plans to apply the
nitrogen midsole to 75 percent of its
Footwear products by 2025 and it's also
starting to build a stable of other Tech
like this material that Anta calls the
shock absorption molecule which the
company describes as bulletproof because
it can absorb almost 100 percent of
shocks when running and jumping
however Nike's continued dominance
partly depends on succeeding on antis
home turf China is the second largest
sportswear market after the U.S and
worth more than 50 billion dollars but
the American company is facing
challenges there
last year Chinese consumers took to
social media to call for a boycott of
Western Brands over allegations about
forced labor and China's cotton-rich
xinjiang region Nike said its sales in
China fell about 20 in its latest
quarter though it pointed to supply
chain disruptions on the flip side this
boycott has created a swell of
nationalism towards homegrown products
like Anta which pledged to continue
using cotton from xinjiang but this
dance has put the company in the
crosshairs of President Biden who signed
a bill that could make it illegal to
import products made with cotton from
the region and to declined to comment
for this video meanwhile Nike in its
latest earnings call set the pipeline of
its innovative products continues to
create the separation between the
company and its competitors
for now anti says China is its largest
source of Revenue and how soon the
company can catch up to Nike on the
international stage could rely on more
than just Tech you have to have that
Foundation of solid technology that
works but a lot of times it's not that
Tech gets who's wearing the tech that's
going to push it forward so besides Clay
Thompson ant has also been working with
other NBA players but to get noticed by
more customers the Chinese company will
need to sign on even more of the bigger
names to its roster of athletes and
endorsements this is a nickel and Cobalt
battery popular in electric vehicles in
the U.S and Europe and this is a
Lithium-Ion phosphate battery also known
as an lfp battery Which is popular in
China it has a shorter range but it's
cheaper to make less prone to fires and
lasts longer both of these batteries
were made by catl a Chinese company
that's the world's largest ev battery
maker of the 10 biggest EV battery
companies six are Chinese China is the
dominant force in EV battery production
while the US is deeply reliant on
foreign batteries the US and China are
David and Goliath situation when it
comes to battery production we're
comparing how the US and China stack up
in the four main stages of battery
production from Vinyl assembly all the
way back to sourcing the raw materials
China assembles more than two-thirds of
the world's electric vehicle battery
cells U.S automakers lag far behind
several companies have outlined plans to
build plants in the U.S but shifting
battery production is difficult
Panasonic a Tesla partner learned this
when it started building a battery plant
at Tesla's gigafactory in Nevada
Panasonic found it couldn't just import
equipment from Asia different safety
regulations and different operating
conditions made it a challenge it also
had to train workers to make batteries a
finicky process where small mistakes can
have major consequences after years of
its joint battery business operating in
the red Tesla and Panasonic's cell
production has become profitable and
it's now a model for other automakers to
follow other companies have found
getting EV battery factories up and
running takes longer than they expect
toward the end of the supply chain is
where the US definitely seems like it
can make the most inroads and then try
to work its way back to traditional
Mining and processing from there it's
the earlier parts of the supply chain
that are more difficult before you can
make finished battery cells you need to
build all the components that make it
work the anodes cathodes separators and
electrolytes China is the global leader
in producing these components the US is
far behind we're talking about working
with very specific chemicals and
materials and turning them into vital
products so there's a lot of safety
testing and everything has to be very
carefully done so that's another reason
China having years of leadership in this
space is so critical because they have
the know-how they're able to adjust to
new technologies and they've been doing
this for a really long time both of
those together make it a really
Herculean task for the US to catch up
the U.S government has invested billions
in companies that are trying to do this
domestically but companies can need
years to develop the technology and ramp
up manufacturing automakers accustomed
to slower development Cycles are trying
to revise battery development strategies
in response to changing mineral prices
and Technology
for example companies have two main
choices when it comes to cathodes the
battery cells most expensive component
nickel and Cobalt used widely in the US
and Europe or lfp common in China U.S
companies have historically preferred
nickel and Cobalt batteries for their
long range but volatile mineral prices
have led some automakers to turn to lfp
batteries while these batteries can't
travel as far between charges they
typically last longer and have better
thermal stability meaning they're more
resistant to heat some U.S automakers
are particularly interested in them for
entry-level Vehicles iron phosphate is
in Vogue now but companies are really
investing in Next Generation batteries
as well companies are always innovating
and trying to change battery chemistries
that's why getting a glimpse of the
supply chain now and how it might change
is really challenging before you can
make components like cathodes and anodes
you need to process and separate the raw
materials that make them up the US
currently does little of this while
China is is the world leader and
companies often have trouble building
chemical processing facilities in the
U.S the bureaucracy here between local
state and federal regulations and then
rules all of that is a messy process
that will take time to work through and
a lot of resources then you have local
opposition oftentimes to these
facilities if there are concerns about
consuming huge amounts of water or
energy or even damaging the local
environment and the last big one is just
labor and supply chain issues like we've
seen throughout the coronavirus pandemic
and then there's the matter of getting
the raw materials most of the minerals
in electric vehicle batteries aren't
mined in the U.S or China they're
imported from countries like Australia
Indonesia and Congo China has strong
relationships with these countries where
it can get raw materials the US is
building new minds domestically and also
building International Partnerships but
both approaches have challenges it can
take up to a decade or more to get new
minds up and running in the U.S
Andromeda materials are only useful once
they can be processed U.S companies are
also trying to go to other countries and
say look we'll develop a mine here in a
country like Ghana or in Africa and then
we'll ship that material to the U.S to
be processed the challenge is a lot more
difficult to do even the processing
facilities in the U.S
in the U.S it's really difficult to get
new mines built and permitted because
there's a lot of environmental
opposition and people just generally
don't like mines in their backyard some
companies though are focused on an
alternative source of materials instead
of mining new materials they're
salvaging minerals from scraps and dead
batteries in the United States right now
we have some lithium
but really no nickel no Cobalt and on
grand scheme relative to all the lithium
that we're going to need we don't have
that much Ascend elements is a U.S
startup focused on producing engineered
EV battery materials it currently
operates a recycling facility in Georgia
and is building a larger one in Kentucky
that may cost up to 1.5 billion dollars
the company says it can produce enough
cathode precursor and active materials
to equip 250 000 EVS per year recycling
startups are among the more promising
American Battery materials suppliers but
they're far from matching the output of
factor trees in China the world's
largest battery recycler and their years
from contributing a meaningful amount of
material to the market the recycled
materials look exactly like a cathode
material made from Virgin material which
is you know mind material send it to a
third-party lab or whatever you couldn't
distinguish between the two Ascend
elements takes used batteries discharges
them and shreds them to recover the
critical components like lithium nickel
and Cobalt while separating out
materials like copper aluminum and
plastic they call the remaining powdery
material Black Mass through this process
Ascend says it recycles up to 98 of the
critical battery materials and does it
with a significantly smaller carbon
footprint than Mining and traditional
cathode manufacturing methods it's
currently focused on making nickel
manganese Cobalt cathode precursors and
active materials recycling may not
enable the US to outpace Chinese
production but it could still will be an
important part of its domestic supply
chain the question isn't really whether
the U.S can catch up to China it
probably can't ever catch up really at
this point given how far ahead China is
but it will take many years for this to
play out a realistic goal is to just
clean up the U.S supply chain so there
is some domestic production of all these
critical components right now they're
just basically at the mercy of China and
these other countries this is much more
about security of basic Supply so that
battery shortages don't become a pinch
point in the energy transition this is
Frontier the U.S supercomputer that was
crowned the world's speediest this year
by the top 500 project which ranks
supercomputing systems globally and the
Machine is able to do one quintillion
calculations per second
write it out that's 18 zeros and that
means it's about 2 billion times faster
than a typical laptop China's tienho 3
didn't participate in this ranking but
some computer scientists say the machine
may be as fast as Frontier the
supercomputers are utilized to solve
some of the most pressing challenges
that humanity is society faces whether
it's developing more advanced spacecraft
or figuring out a Greener future both
countries are racing to build faster
machines so to better solve the
challenges the US has opened up Frontier
to scientists around the world and we
got access to look inside it in order to
compare its design with Tian hu 3 and
see what it takes to build one of the
world's speediest supercomputers
we want to provide this level of compute
capability that has never never been
achieved before Thomas Zechariah is the
director of Oak Ridge National
Laboratory in Tennessee a lab sponsored
by the U.S department of energy he's
worked on over a dozen supercomputers in
the US and now leads the team that
oversees the operation of Frontier U.S
has been a leader in in super Computing
for a long long time since the 1960s U.S
supercomputers have mostly dominated the
field until China joined the race China
really started dealing with high
performance computers in a serious way
back in 2001. Jack dongara is a computer
scientist based in the U.S and he's one
of the founders of the top 500 project
he's been closely watching China since
it made its debut on the list in 2001.
it's quite a change over a very short
period of time roughly 20 years going
from nothing to being dominant China
hasn't revealed how much it's invested
in super Computing but since 2006
Beijing has put it into the country's
Five-Year Plan which is a blueprint for
China's Economic Development today the
country has more Super computers on the
top 500 lists than the us but this year
Chinese researchers didn't submit tn03's
results and some computer scientists say
given how quickly Chinese machines have
improved Tian ho 3 may be as fast as
Frontier reaching the speed of a
quintillion calculations per second
scientists call this exascale
performance and to do that both the U.S
and China started with this part A
compute node is fundamentally the
building block of a supercomputer an
individual compute node is basically
like your personal computer and take
Frontier as an example it mainly has two
sets of chips the central processing
units or CPUs are the heart of the
machine that carries out instructions
and accelerators help boost the
performance of the CPUs so you can
imagine supercomputer stacking up a
whole bunch of those individual Shooters
with a very very fast Network
so this is what a frontier cabinet looks
like frontiac has got 74 cabinets each
cabinet is about 8 000 pounds it has
9408 nodes
the nodes are connected to everyone each
other and can transfer information very
fast
Tiano 3 also has cabinets with compute
nodes but China hasn't disclosed the
size of its machine some computer
scientists say that based on state media
footage and presentations by Tien HUD
3's researchers the machine may have a
hundred cabinets and more than 50 000
nodes
but what really differentiates these two
massive supercomputers are the tiny
chips inside because they're key to
deciding the speed and Computing
capabilities and that's an area where
the US has an advantage over China
American scientists have access to some
of the most cutting-edge Technologies
from semiconductor designers and
producers at home and Frontiers 2 chips
come from one of the leading American
Semiconductor developers Advanced Micro
Devices Zechariah says the company has
worked closely with the lab to design
these chips and that partnership has
held Frontier officially become the
first exascale machine these are the
latest in their evolution they are
designed and manufactured processors
specifically with a view to building the
supercomputer and delivering the
performance that is needed China on the
other hand has not had a home field
advantage with chips it used to rely on
American companies like Intel and Nvidia
but that became impossible in 2015 when
the US barred its semiconductor makers
from selling to Chinese institutions
that develop supercomputers Inc
including the one that builds tn03 so
the Tien have people who were planning
to build the next machine decided that
they needed to because they couldn't use
western parts they had to design their
own chips China's national supercomputer
Center didn't respond to a request for
comment about the performance and Chip
design of tienho 3.
But ultimately building these
supercomputers isn't just about
achieving fast speed it goes back to
science and doing the best science so
countries that have the fastest
supercomputers can carry out simulations
which have greater Fidelity and they can
get results back much quicker for
example getting those results quickly
was critical during the pandemic
Frontier was deployed to analyze 11
million genomes to better distinguish
and predict variants it has given us
Clues to develop the next generation of
vaccines the next generation of
Therapeutics to not only you know treat
and prevent covid but also for other
kind of ailments and to better solve
some of the world's most pressing
challenges the lab is awarding
scientists from around the world time to
use Frontier based on the Merit of their
research and in turn they're required to
publish their findings it's an important
part of doing science is exchanging
information we express our ideas and
show one choice as we better than
another and through that exchange we
hopefully end up with a better situation
China has also said it welcomed
scientists from other countries to run
research on Tien ho3 but so far the
machine has only been used by
institutions backed by the Chinese
government like the country's top
research group the Chinese Academy of
Sciences the annoying thing is that you
know we don't hear much about these
computers in the west it's a problem I
would say I'm waiting for the time we
can have more interchanges until then
this segregation of research could slow
down progress even as both the U.S and
China are united in finding ways to
accelerate their supercomputers China
has the largest high-speed rail network
in the world spanning over 40 000
kilometers and of the 10 fastest trains
in the world four are in China and
China's busiest high-speed train the
Beijing Shanghai rail runs 217 miles per
hour the U.S however tells a much
different story its high-speed rail
system spans 700 and 35 kilometers and
its fastest train Amtrak's Acela Express
goes just 150 miles per hour and only
for a few minutes on part of the track
since 2008 China has rapidly built up
its high-speed rail network the US in
that time has had several High-Speed
Rail projects shelved or delayed here's
how the US has fallen behind China in
High-Speed Rail technology
one key difference between the U.S and
China has to do with the tracks the
trains run on in the case of the U.S as
we can see a lot of the north sister
corridors are based on hundreds years of
the old tracks there are also tunnels
and a curvatures and bridges that are
really owed that cannot really allow the
trains to run at a faster speed these
tracks were originally built for Freight
and passenger trains to use at the same
time so they have many points of
intersections and crossings and the
Acela runs on this track but China has
tracks that are dedicated to High-Speed
Rail they are really requires to have a
more smoother curves has also they
needed to have a more slower gradients
and so that allowed the trains to roam
smoothly and safely one of the reasons
trains in America can't reach their top
speeds is because of how the tracks are
designed even though the trains are
capable for Amtrak to run 186 they'll
never see more than 160 miles per hour
because the infrastructure is still
being developed and isn't quite there
yet
to Curves on the tracks many
conventional passenger trains in the U.S
only operate 10 to 15 miles per hour
faster than freight trains on the curved
portion of tracks but China built its
High-Speed Rail on elevated tracks
traveling on what's called viaducts so
the tolerance is in high speed are
pretty pretty precise pretty tightly
defined and so the track and overhead
wires need to be designed in a way to be
able to allow those higher speeds
there's also a difference in where
stations are located in China stations
for high-speed rails are located in both
suburban and rural areas of the country
whereas in the U.S stations are
primarily located in urban centers like
New York City Boston and Washington DC
when you're looking to identify where a
high speed line should go it really
starts with where are the two population
centers you're trying to connect
and the magic formula is really fine two
City pairs that have a minimum of three
million people on either side and a
distance of about two to five hundred
miles in order to achieve a higher speed
definitely a dedicated passenger rail
system is more needed despite the fact
that the US has been slow to develop
High-Speed Rail railroads actually used
to dominate Interstate Transportation
but that shifted during the mid 20th
century when the interstate highway
system was born since then American
history has been littered with
High-Speed Rail plans that never really
took off automobile and air travel and
the car travel is essentially become the
major modes of travel in the U.S to make
that kind of behavior change that
basically needs a lot of efforts to help
people understand why this is a need to
have another mode and what are the
benefits of that China's High-Speed Rail
however consistently had backing from
the government investing billion
millions of dollars including initial
partners with foreign firms contracts
were awarded on the condition that
foreign companies assembled the trains
and also trained Chinese Engineers so
they're trying to understand that the
foreign Technologies how it works but
they're also trying to make certain
Innovations on top of that eventually
China developed its own train
Manufacturing Company the crrc and now
the crrc is one of the largest train
manufacturers in the world in the case
of china because it's a central
government system so large
infrastructure projects like high speed
rail system can be really developed
based on a kind of consistent plan the
U.S has also had foreign companies come
to the country to develop a high-speed
rail network but it's been met with
several challenges take for example
Illinois back in 2019 Nippon shario of
Japan tried to build a high-speed rail
in the states however the companies
struggled to adapt designs to the US and
faced delays in getting new rail cars
and changing administrations doesn't
help California approved a plan in 2008
to build a high-speed rail network but
the project has been delayed because of
a lack of funding and inconsistent
support the train technology is already
here but what we're seeing right now in
the U.S at this specific moment in time
is not that dissimilar to what was
happening in Europe in the 1970s where
there was initially a lot of concern or
objection about trying to do something
new and it wasn't until the first system
started to be put in place and people
saw the real promise that you know high
speed was able to deliver on and then
once the political and public support
was behind it it really took off and
grew
this is how big Tech in the U.S
envisions the future of the internet
avatars like this one playing games
buying digital assets socializing ah yes
the metaverse and Chinese tech companies
are piling in too their versions of
avatars and Virtual Worlds look pretty
similar but because of China's strict
regulations players in the two countries
are said to have very different
experiences
analysts estimate the metaverse industry
could be worth as much as 8 trillion
dollars in each country but it's still
early days for both Chinese and American
Tech firms
the visual effects seen in promo videos
for a metaverse platform being built by
Chinese Tech Giant Baidu are still
pretty pixelated and lego-like
quite a ways off the smooth immersive
World some have in mind similarly
Facebook's parent company meta's avatars
are still legless and not particularly
realistic in the early version of its VR
platform Horizon worlds which lets
people build custom environments to hang
out or play games in and is already
available in the US and Canada
both meta and Baidu have set an official
launch for their respective platforms
will take another five to ten years
Microsoft in the US and tencent in China
which both own a number of video gaming
properties are also gearing up to
develop their own virtual worlds
but for companies in China the
transition to the metaverse is expected
to be a little more complicated
Chinese companies are subject to more
regulations than in the US Winston ma is
the author of China's mobile economy and
managing partner at new york-based
cloudtree Ventures which invests in
metaverse related Tech like 3D video
recording companies are taking a more
cautious approach because of regulatory
considerations that's a big difference
between the US and China
compared to China companies in the US
generally have more leeway from
regulators and people in the industry
say that gives metaverse developers more
free reign in terms of innovation
meaning China's rules are expected to
affect the user experience in other
words these two avatars won't
necessarily be able to see say and do
the same things
[Music]
universes and the Western Metal versus
sir Khan Toto is a gaming industry
consultant he says video games offer a
window into what the metaverse will be
like and in China games have to go
through a rigorous approval process by
authorities before they can be released
he pointed to a violent first-person
shooter game in the version of the game
available to play in China the blood is
green instead of red because of
beijing's content regulations that
restrict Gore and violence rules in
China also limit how long the country's
hundreds of millions of kids under 18
can game as Regulators have said they
want to prevent user addiction these
rules and regulations that are already
in place are going to be transferred
over to the metaverse there's no
motivation for the Chinese government to
soften their stance just because the
game is embedded inside the metaverse
Chinese officials have already indicated
that some strict rules will apply to the
metaverse and established a subcommittee
that according to policy experts aims to
create specific standards for these
Virtual Worlds
those authorities didn't respond to
requests for comment
and state media was quick to Tamp down
the hype after a recent rally of Chinese
metaverse related stocks warning Society
not to get too wrapped up in metaverse
speculation
Chinese Regulators are also extremely
cautious about digital payment systems
which are already how people buy things
in metaverse-like platforms available in
the US such as Roblox sandbox or
decentraland in the U.S lots of
metaverse place involve in-game crypto
tokens and nfts but in China
cryptocurrencies are strictly regulated
last year the Chinese government
declared cryptocurrency transactions
illegal saying it was concerned that
cryptos decentralized Anonymous
transactions could give way to fraud and
money laundering
authorities have instead promoted the
use of a central bank issued virtual un
so buying art or digital concert tickets
with crypto isn't possible in China
and that could contribute to further
insulating China's own metaverse
platforms at the moment at least if
companies like tencent are building
metaverses there's not going to be any
kind of tokens in them these companies
are challenged now to come up with
Alternatives that the Chinese government
is going to tolerate
in this context analysts say metaverses
like baidu's probably won't face direct
competition from meta or Microsoft in
the Chinese market which when it comes
to the internet is already separate from
the rest of the world Facebook and
Google for example don't operate in
China because of strict censorship
Microsoft and meta didn't respond to
requests for comment on their metaverse
plans for China the future of the
Chinese meta verses will be a reflection
of the Chinese internet today there's
really going to be a huge wall between
these metaverses
this is Jeff base blue origin rocket
ship that takes tours to the edge of
orbit
and this is a model from cast space a
Chinese company that's been tapped by
the government to send its first tours
to space as soon as 2024. we compare the
two vehicles because the company that
can perfect the reusable space rocket
and make it cheaper could get one of the
first cracks at accessing the larger
space economy
welcome to space
in 2021 a flurry of commercial space
flights pioneered by American companies
began taking off and they've been
working for years to develop their
vehicles and recently China decided to
join the race last year cast space which
was created by the country's top
scientific Think Tank laid out plans for
its space rocket China's rather a late
Comer in space tourism but then also
very aggressive in their timelines
Blaine Curcio is a space industry
consultant and he focuses on the Chinese
and U.S markets providing analysis for
commercial space companies that look to
broaden their footprint caspase they
talk about wanting to have their first
demonstration flight of their space
tourism vehicle in 2022 and then finally
space tours like actual space tours and
flights by 2024 though a lot of
uncertainties lie ahead for this
commercial project Curcio says these
deadlines aren't impossible
in the past few years China's national
space program has had a good track
record it was the first to land a Rover
on The Far Side of the Moon they sent
another one to Mars and started building
its own space station so to catch up
caspase is planning to offer flights too
its trips will look less like SpaceX
we're seeing the world every 90 minutes
and Virgin Galactic
foreign
but more like blue origin
they are going to the edge of space
where people have a couple of minutes of
weightlessness Quentin Parker's been
researching Global space programs for
over 40 years and has recently been
focused on projects coming out of China
the design of these Rockets is driven
strongly by what you need to do with it
so blue origin and caspase have similar
designs and both say the journey is
about 10 minutes
first the rocket will launch up into the
sky then it will release the capsule
that carries the Taurus as a rocket
comes back down vertically the capsule
will continue into sub-orbital flight
going across the Carmen line an
imaginary boundary between Earth's
atmosphere and outer space then the
capsule will return to Earth separately
blue origin completed three human
flights last year
using the same vehicle for each trip
while caspase hasn't tested a rocket the
company says it's also designing one
that will be reusable reusability is
what drives down the costs so
significantly and makes so many of these
plans viable
one key to reusability is at the bottom
the engines are designed to throttle and
restart
so they can be fired to take off as well
as control The Landing but this is where
both companies designs start to look
different blue origin relies on only one
engine which is worked stably for each
of its human flights according to
caspase its rocket will use five of
these Parker says multiple engines could
provide more thrusting points to help
ensure that the rocket remains intact if
you have five engines
then if one uh misbehaves you could
possibly compensate with the other four
there's another factor that could
determine what kind of reusable rocket
may become the popular model the rocket
fuel blue origin uses a combination of
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen while
caspase is planning on using kerosene
and liquid oxygen and both choices have
environmental and financial pros and
cons kerosene mixed with liquid oxygen
is dirtier than what the blue origin
does but it's actually much much cheaper
blue origin founder Jeff Bezos has said
working with liquid hydrogen is
challenging but that this fuel component
would be important for the company's
future projects caspase said the design
of its engine is meant to keep costs low
so it's actually if you're going
commercial you need to see what is the
best option and it becomes a more viable
commercial proposition you can make a
profit and to make these plans
commercially viable blue Origins rocket
and the one planned by caspase would use
different Landing systems the Chinese
company is designing a tower that will
catch the rocket whereas blue origin
uses fins drag brakes and Landing legs
to help it touch down softly
these companies are still weighing how
much to invest and determining the
demand for these types of trips since
reserving a seat is expensive
but mastering the reusable technology
ultimately isn't only about tourism
space tourism is a very small part of
the overall space economy right now but
in terms of the technology side of
things reusable Rockets are definitely a
really big enabler of a lot of other
things the race for a better rocket
includes launching satellites and
sending crew and cargo to space stations
even one day facilitating deep space
exploration to the moon or Mars
but industry experts say there's
currently a launch bottleneck for some
of these missions because there aren't
enough rockets and building one can take
months if not years and costs millions
or even billions of dollars
so the company that could perfect the
reusable technology would not just help
relieve that bottleneck but also grab a
larger slice of the growing industry
blue origin and cast space didn't
respond to our requests for comment
for China these commercial possibilities
could help further open up its Space
Program which has been strictly
controlled by the government they want
commercial companies to play a bigger
role in Innovation so I think that's
going to be increasingly important even
for the things like you know the
high-level civil training Space Program
and for U.S companies these commercial
possibilities May mean a closer
relationship with NASA which has already
partnered with blue origin for its
launch services for now the Space Race
For Taurus is just the first step we're
still waiting for the game changer in
terms of the propulsion technology but
reusable rockets and reusable Tech are
making big strides around the world and
getting more efficient and more reliable
and more safe and if this game changer
arrives it'll open up the potential of a
much larger future in space for both the
U.S and China
this is the Nancy Grace Roman survey
telescope or Roman for short NASA is set
to launch it into space in 2027. and
this is China's survey telescope
chantian that's set to launch a few
years earlier than Roman these two
telescopes are racing to map the
universe in more detail than ever before
in the hopes of solving some of
science's greatest Mysteries like how a
little understood Force known as dark
energy helped shape our universe
potentially there's even a Nobel Prize
there right if you figure out what dark
energy is so we unpacked the technology
and Behind These telescopes because a
country that can capture the best images
may lead the future of astrophysics
research
space telescopes are crucial tools for
avoiding the light pollution and
Distortion that limits ground-based
telescopes when they look out at space
from inside the Earth's atmosphere
an American physicist first proposed
space-based observatories in 1946 and
then about two decades later the U.S
sent up the first operational Space
Telescope the Soviet Union was close
behind sending up its own first space
telescopes only a few years later
since 1990 the field has been dominated
by NASA's Hubble until the recent launch
of the James Webb Space Telescope or
jwst for short both Hubble and genuine
St are telescopes that look at a very
small part of the sky in a lot of detail
Jonathan McDowell is an astrophysicist
at the Harvest Smithsonian Center for
astrophysics he's worked with NASA and
has been monitoring space activities and
satellites for three decades they aren't
used to kind of look around and go oh I
wonder if we'll see something here you
look at something you already know is
there and you stare at it in detail
this is where the race to build the next
generation of telescopes comes in with
survey telescopes that can map out large
areas of the sky
NASA's Nancy Grace Roman is named after
the agency's first Chief astronomer
shontan is China's first ever Space
Telescope and translates to survey of
the heavens in Chinese let's make no
bones about it they're both fantastic
and amazing facilities Quinton Parker is
an astrophysicist and the director of
the laboratory for space research at the
University of Hong Kong he's been
observing the rapid acceleration of
China's space program for over the past
decade you know surveys by their nature
throw up incredible things you don't
know what they're going to find
both telescopes are designed to learn
more about Dark Energy a mysterious
pressure that scientists believe is
responsible for the accelerating
expansion of the universe and the
galaxies inside it that will let us
understand how our galaxy evolved how
the chemical elements in our galaxy
evolved how we got here
but there are currently no telescopes
that can detect Dark Energy even though
scientists say it makes up around 70
percent of the total energy of the
universe so the goal is for scientists
to use shuntan and Roman to uncover Dark
Energy Secrets we're not collecting
signatures from Dark Energy directly
we're looking at the way that this
interaction with things that we can
measure so U.S and Chinese researchers
are racing to build telescopes that can
answer the same question but each with a
different design one difference is in
the telescope's mirrors so if you throw
a certain amount of light at the
telescope right
um some fraction of it is reflected by
the mirror and some fraction of that is
captured by the camera
Roman's mirror is larger than shuntians
which means it will be able to capture
more light giving the final image more
detail but even though chantan's mirror
is smaller in diameter it has a field of
view that's more than three times wider
this means it'll be able to image more
of the sky over the course of its
Mission than Roman
Washingtonian may have an edge on image
size the quality depends on another
important part of the telescope the
sensor module
the sensor reads and processes the light
captured by the mirror and sends back
information to Earth for scientists to
turn into amazing images like these ones
from the James Webb Telescope
so having a less powerful sensor can
create problems for the images that are
produced you are likely to get images
with more artifacts in them with more
noise
with less Sensitivity I can't see quite
as faint Stars things like that McDowell
says NASA's six Decades of experience
creating sensors that work under the
extreme conditions of space give it an
advantage over China's younger space
agency the challenge for China is can
they match the the sort of semiconductor
technology aspects of NASA's cameras by
having more experience with telescopes
NASA can also be more ambitious about
how far it sends Roman the telescope
will orbit the Sun from a distance of
about 1 million miles from Earth that
means Roman will be able to operate
without constant changes in light and
temperature and NASA says that allows
the telescope to collect data constantly
shintan on the other hand will stay
close to the Earth and therefore be
regularly blocked as it orbits Limited
the amount of time it can spend
collecting data but being that far away
also means Roman can't be repaired if
anything goes wrong
tan will be near the Chinese space
station giving scientists on board
access to the telescope if needed you
can actually not only can you repair it
it gets damaged or if the solar panels
gets damaged or something goes wrong you
can upgrade it you can replace the
camera you can put on new filters new
instrumentation give it a new lease of
life keep it going for longer
however what could be the most important
Advantage is shuntan's launch date China
space agency says it's going up in 2023
giving it about a four-year head start
on Roman they may steal some of the
Thunder from what the Roman telescope
would have done NASA said in a statement
that shuntan's observations will
complement its Mission and Roman has
unique capabilities for the study of
dark energy China's Space Administration
didn't respond to a request for comment
on shintan's launch schedule and design
scientists say both telescopes will play
a significant role in learning more
about the origins of the universe
there's a lot of international
recognition if you you know if you start
to elucidate what's going on in the in
the early universe but only one country
can lay claim to being the first to make
the biggest discoveries in astrophysics